land und brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten morgen sichert gut belogen
markus wo er sich in der
kriminalist wieder da sehr gut in meinem
bekanntenkreis macht das jetzt wirklich
die runde das wort kemenate ist finde
ich schön ich hatte bevor wir loslegen
ich habe heute ein thema von dem ich
wirklich interessiert was du dazu denkst
und sagst aber erst mal müssen uns
bedanken in kürzester zeit über eine
halbe million abrufe bei youtube
wenn wir unseren ersten video podcast
gemacht kannte ich vorher gar nicht und
bin völlig verblüfft und fasziniert
davon und auch ehrlich gesagt sehr
dankbar dass das so gut funktioniert
historia das sehr gute gelegenheit sich
mal bei allen zu bedanken die sich auch
anschauen und anhören ja ich als ich
habe wahnsinnig viel resonanz bekommen
die leute sind dem von dir besonders
begeistert emily kürten darf ich ihm
ausnahmsweise sagen die tochter des
legendären dieter kürten hat sich
gemeldet und und schrieb wortwörtlich
wie gut dass es menschen wie richard
david precht gibt ja also sie hat
vergessen mich zu erwähnen dem
zusammenhang dass er sie aber nicht übel
ich liebe sie trotzdem sie geht davon
aus dass sie weiß das
quartal ist gut aber es war ich wollte
ich dir nur sagen es war ein sehr
ehrliches und nett gemeintes kompliment
richard ich wollte mit dir heute über
etwas reden ein wort ein begriff mit dem
ich ehrlich gesagt lange nicht
konfrontiert war immer wieder mal taucht
er in der sendung auf und ich merke
immer wieder wie sich auch politiker
drumrum drücken aber mittlerweile ist es
langsam offenkundig wir kommen nicht
mehr daran vorbei in deutlich und klar
auszusprechen dieser tage ein stück von
dem von mir sehr geschätzten jacobi weit
gelesen großartiger spiegel autor der
auch sagte verzicht ist wirklich der
begriff die vokabel der stunde und es
ist für viele ich rede jetzt nicht von
wirklich bedürftigen menschen aber für
viele ein irres gefühl ich glaube dass
gerade menschen meiner generation
die kennen das nicht die müssen
plötzlich lernen dass es nicht mehr
alles und sofort auf knopfdruck gibt ja
bisher gab es alles im überfluss
in den letzten jahren sogar unmittelbar
auf knopfdruck geliefert dann von amazon
prime am ende man musste nicht mal mehr
auf geöffnete läden warten usw und
plötzlich erlebst du quasi den
gegenentwurf zu amazon prime wir warten
auf ware warten auf flugzeuge jahr
hunderttausende urlauber zuerst in
england die nicht losfliegen konnten
jetzt plötzlich auch in deutschland
heute gelesen die lufthansa entschuldigt
sich ganz offiziell und sagt 2023 wird
es vielleicht besser aber wir haben kein
personal wir haben keine flugzeuge wir
können euch nicht mehr garantiert und
verbindlich zu einer bestimmten zeit in
den urlaub bringen christian lindner der
darauf hinweist oder in drastischen
worten warnt es werden jahre des mannes
auf uns zukommen und robert habeck sagte
es könnte sein dass wir sehr bald in
kalten wohnungen sitzen und das wird
möglicherweise alles schlimmer als bei
corona das
vivaz geht den kopf wenn du das wären
als erster erstmal meinst du ja genauso
wie ich wir reden jetzt von von der
durchschnittsbevölkerung
wir reden erinnere an den menschen die
tatsächlich jeden tag verzichten müssen
weil sie sehr wenig geld haben weil sie
niemals hier leben und zur gesagt
sondern wir reden jetzt sagen aber so
richtig so von der von der deutschen
durchschnitts erfahrung und genau da war
das ja tatsächlich so dass über die
jahrzehnte seit ich lebe ist immer alles
mehr geworden alles ist schneller
geworden als es ist mehr geworden und
jetzt erleben wir aus meiner sicht der
fast ganz gespenstisches wenn wir jetzt
eine große debatte haben über das thema
verzicht dann meinen wir dass wir
verzichten müssen weil sich unser
verhältnis zu russland geändert hat
durch den russischen angriffskrieg man
weil wir uns von russland nicht mehr
abhängig machen dürfen und
ich hätte nie damit gerechnet dass das
im jahr 2022 der grund für verzicht sein
würde ich habe natürlich damit gerechnet
dass sie im jahr 2022 über verzicht
reden aber aus einem ganz anderen grund
nämlich aus dem ökologischen grund
während ich hier sitze gucke ich auf
meine bibliothek halben meter entfernt
da habe ich fast einen ganzen regalen
meter nur mit büchern
wo es darum geht in zukunft weniger zu
verbrauchen
wohlstand zu reduzieren und so weiter ja
also ich hab hier gerade ein buch gegen
das heißt genug das ist von einem times
autor aus dem jahr 2008 john live bei
damals wahnsinnig erfolgreich ist genau
die gerne einfach mal die sache gerne
ich lebe jetzt einfach mal mit ganz ganz
wenigen dingen und gucken ob das klappt
und ich würde gerne wissen was aus dem
heute geworden ist ob er immer noch so
erlebt und ich hab nämlich im
klappentext gerade gedruckt vorsteherin
dass er kein fernseher hat so und das
war 2008 was ganz besonderes jemand hat
keinen fernseher inbegriffen
heute müsste sich die frage stellen hat
er kein smartphone ja kein
internetzugang und also da hat sich auch
unglaublich viel verändert das heißt
also worauf man heute verzichten müsste
wäre unglaublich viel mehr als noch 2008
also gerade mal 14 jahre
und ich war 2008 das war die zeit viele
bücher die ich hier vor mir sehe sind
bücher die genau aus dieser zeit stammen
das war die zeit wo wirklich viel
darüber diskutiert wurde brauchen wir
weiter wirtschaftswachstum und so weiter
ich ein buch von meinhard miegel ja der
glaube an die berater von von kurt
biedenkopf war genauso ursprünglich
cdu-politiker der gesagt hat ja wir
können es gibt kein unbegrenztes
wachstum in einer begrenzten welt und so
und heute haben wir die grünen in der
regierung
die würden aber nicht von verzicht reden
wenn wir nicht in folge des krieges
davon reden müssen ist das nicht irre
dass der ukraine krieg dazu führt dass
die menschen bei uns bereit sein werden
sollen könnten zu verzichten name die
zerstörung des planeten für die
enkelgeneration dass das kein motiv ist
das auch nur ansatzweise so stark ist ja
so was was man ja auf werden sitzt der
geschichte in wer ist es ja jeder macht
einen großen bogen um dieses thema
das ist wirklich unglaublich liegt das
in der sendung immer wieder nicht mal
das wort tempolimit traut sich eine mund
zu nehmen du kannst das wurde doch noch
von der fdp ganz schnell aus dem
koalitionsvertrag gestrichen war das
nicht so ja also hört dass sie gesagt
haben also ihr könnt ja von uns fordert
was ihr wollt aber tempolimit die gar
nicht genug das ist du weißt es gibt
dieses dieses herrliche bonbon auf
volker wissing der aktuelle
bundesverkehrsminister
dr irgendwann in die ecke gedrängt auf
die frage wie sie das jetzt mit dem
tempolimit irgendwann nur noch sagte er
wir haben ja gar nicht genügend tun der
30 schilder können wir ja gar nicht
fertig sender zu nehmen und ich hatte
ein anderes erlebnis letzte woche
diesbezüglich mit dem von mir sehr sehr
sehr geschätzten alexander graf
lambsdorff der toller diplomat ist und
der auch ein historiker ist der ja
unglaublich gut größere globale
geostrategische zusammenhänge erklären
kann ist echt guter mann unter einer
davon der der belegt dass in der ersten
reihe der deutschen politik und ein paar
sehr sehr gute leute unterwegs sind und
er sagte aber dann auch irgendwie auf
die frage nach einem autofreien sonntag
sagte er es geht gar nicht am sonntag
muss man oma besuchen
und dann bin ich fast handgreiflich
sagte entschuldigen besuchen sie doch
mal am samstag es ist so unfassbar dass
jetzt die oma herhalten muss ja erklärt
warum wir nicht mal am sonntag aufs
autofahren verzichten können die oma die
wir klammer auf schon seit jahren nicht
mehr besucht haben klammer zu hören wie
gut
das ist das ist alles verrückt also wir
gehen davon aus dass es durchaus
passieren kann dass viele menschen im
nächsten winter frieden halten das dann
aber für zumutbar halten aber ein
tempolimit nicht für zumutbar
also ich deutschland sind auch schon
schräges völkchen das kann man nicht
anders sagen
dass mit dem tempolimit ist also dort wo
die sonne letzte trotz bastion sowie das
lange sind schon lange das rauchen in
öffentlichen gebäuden und so weiter war
du kennst ja ich bringe das beispiel mit
dem rauchverbot ja gerne weil ich ein
paar von den dieser diskussion drin ich
habe darüber auch text geschrieben
kommentare und so weiter ist das
rauchverbot in öffentlichen räumen und
es die leute gesagt haben das werden wir
nie nie niemals machen ja das kann man
uns nicht zu das ist freiheitsberaubung
und so weiter wer damit heute schreibt
normalste von der welt kein mensch regt
sich mehr auf die leute haben sich
völlig dran gewöhnt und keiner kann sich
vorstellen bei einem guten restaurant
sitzt und vom nebentisch qual und einem
100 sie gar aus essen ja das heißt also
heute ist das gegenteil nicht mehr
vorstellbar oder wie wir hat damals mit
der anschnallpflicht im auto riesen
diskussion so in meiner kindheit war ich
so zehn als das eingeführt wurde ich
kann mich an männer erinnern also
aggressiv werden die männer die gesagt
er werde im juli im land nicht
anschnallen und so also
solche dinge wie tempolimit durch
zusammen jetzt eher leere in meinem
leben keine maske tragen egal wo wir
stehen ja also die die regel dahinter
ist ja die menschen unterschätzen ihre
eigene anpassungsfähigkeit gewaltig das
ist es so und diese anpassungsfähigkeit
die wäre bei einem tempolimit wäre die
da und beim autofreien sonntag und so
weit mehr energie da ein politiker
trauen sich nicht so richtig schade wenn
jemand wie lambsdorff der einflussreiche
europapolitiker ist nur dass er sich da
kein ruck gibt und ich verstehe was die
stunde geschlagen hat und daher versteht
es ganz genau dafür ist ja aber jetzt
ärger mit seiner partei sei der der der
schnell fahrenden autos ja genau das ist
ja auch in ordnung also man darf die
position nach haben mich ist jetzt
eigentlich um das um das jahr hat jeder
hat eine andere position der eine will
dann hoffentlich verzichten der andere
will darauf was ich versichern und am
ende wird das nix mit dem verzicht ja
genau das ist der punkt man wir bayern
sozusagen unfassbaren dieses wort
verzichtet und dann wird er noch immer
gerne gesagt na ja also tempo 130 nicht
mal ralf staege nach 30 das laut zu
sagen ralf stegner sagt zum beispiel ist
ein wirklicher linker aus der spd ja
eine der den jugend auch sehr schätze
weil einfach gnadenlos durch zieht in
seiner position immer der steht zu dem
was er sagt dass jemand der ganz wenig
angst vor den massenmedien ja totaler
angstfrei möglicher finde ich auch er
hat keine angst davor immer lediglich
ausdruck als hätte er gerade eine
zitrone im mund oder was verfaultes
gegessen ja aber unglaublich
prinzipientreue aufrechter mensch ja ja
finde ich also die ist einmal die die
die form seiner mundwinkel passt aber
auch nicht zu seinem innersten kern
möchte ich sagen also auch ralf stegner
wirkt immer so ein bisschen griesgrämig
ist ein sehr honoriger mensch wenn man
immer ein bisschen besser erkennt dass
man durchaus vorstellen genau dieses
verzichte ich habe neulich an ein tolles
stück von
hilmar klute in der süddeutschen gelesen
der sich darüber lustig machte dass wir
ja so eine verwöhnte hafer milch
gesellschaft hinten ein team mit
verzicht nicht mehr umgehen kann und
dann schreibt er etwas ganz ganz
großartiges pass auf sagt angesichts der
über griffigkeit putins sind zwar viele
deutsche zwischendurch zu potenziellen
winter helden geworden die für den
niedergang des aggressors eine runde
frieren würden wie sie sagen und er auch
nur eine runde nicht 2 und robert ist
klug genug achtung all die freizeit
partisanen in ihrer lustigen
selbstüberschätzung zu erkennen wollen
sie vor der eigenen misere zu schützen
das ist ja wirklich wunderschöne
verliert ja aber das mit dem freizeit
partie sahen da ist eine menge dran also
ich glaube die leute überschätzen gerade
ihren ihrem ökonomischen heldenmut und
ihre aufopferungsbereitschaft
also ich glaube ich glaube tatsächlich
dass das eine sehr ernste
gesellschaftliche auseinandersetzung
werden könnte wenn es dazu kommt dass
tatsächlich im winter kein russisches
gas mehr kommt ja absolut das wissen wir
ja noch nicht ob es dazu kommt oder ob
es nicht dazu kommt aber wenn das
tatsächlich droht
dann geht etwas auf was wir uns so übel
gar nicht haben ausmalen können das ist
nämlich passiert dass die russische
wirtschaft aufgrund der sanktionen
natürlich viel stärker belastet ist als
unsere putin das aber innenpolitisch
viel besser übersteht weil er in ein
land regiert in nehmen die leute
verzicht und ärger und niedergang und
all das gewöhnt sind und wir in einer
kultur wo der allerkleinste und feinste
rückschritt und der allerkleinste
verzicht und so weiter gehen als
unzumutbar empfunden wird viel größere
innenpolitische querelen dafür kriegen
das kann am ende tatsächlich so
idiotisch das ist aber das kann
tatsächlich eintreten das ist so ein
bisschen somit der waffentechnik man
sagt ja immer dass sie die russischen
waffen die zum teil eingesetzt werden
zum teil so auf dem niveau des zweiten
weltkriegs sind ja aber wenn man
unglaublich viel davon einsetzt sei zwar
irgendwie auch sein ziel und wir haben
diese ganzen intelligenten hochsensiblen
waffen umfassen systeme wo also jemand
erst mal ein halbes jahr an lernen muss
damit er sie überhaupt bedienen kann das
heißt also unsere westlichen
gesellschaften sind fragil ja sensibel
kompliziert und fragil
und ja ich könnte mir durchaus
vorstellen dass das eine große debatte
wird in der zweiten hälfte des jahres
worauf menschen bereit sein werden zu
verzichten ist richtig du weißt ja ne
also auch juristisch ich erinnere mich
es gab eine zeit da wurde sehr genau
erklärt was dann passieren würde er als
die ersten notfall stufen sozusagen in
kraft getreten sind und jetzt sind wir
bei stufe 2 und die dritte stufe ist
dann wenn es um gas geht der staat
übernimmt und teilt dann sozusagen die
gaslieferungen zu und sagt wer zuerst
und wer wieviel und wer möglicherweise
nichts mehr das ist eine ganz ganz harte
entscheidung und da gibt es auch
offensichtlich listen und pläne wie so
etwas zu laufen hat und es ist
eigentlich
nicht nur eigentlich soll das ist
juristisch sozusagen festgeschrieben
dass privathaushalte erst ganz zum
schluss
rationiert werden ja das hat ja was
dadurch einfach nur von der wählerschaft
her verständlich ist und genau was
gerichtlich in den teufelskreis führen
wenn der industrie das gasfeld genau ist
das natürlich wirtschaftlich noch
belastender naja es gibt ja es gibt
einen hoffnungsschimmer markus dem
darfst du nicht vergessen die fußball wm
in katar findet ja in diesem winter
statt ja und wenn die stube noch so kalt
ist du kannst dich ja dann hinsetzen und
ihren glühwein einschenken ja und dich
an den spielen aids und dann guckst du
da in der es ins heiße katar jaha und
erhitzt sich am spiel ja und das hilft
uns dann darüber in unseren kalten
stuben aus natur erhitzt sich an der
tatsache dass diese wm überhaupt dort
stattfindet ja dann werde ich mich so
lange erhalten bis sie zu ende ist und
danach werde ich mich weiter darüber er
hilft er seine heizung kannst du schon
mal ausgelassen in diesem winter dass
ich das sehe ich kommen genau also bei
mir hat sich in hinblick auf katar so
viel so viel gesagt ich kann gar nicht
frieren die restwärme des ärgers über
katar die erreicht bis bis märz april
kommen unbedingt die finger weißt du was
interessant ist tatsächlich die die
debatte verändert sich also am anfang
war das völlig klar privathaushalte das
sind die den ganz zum schluss erst der
gashahn zugedreht wird plötzlich werden
aber andere stimmen laut richtig harte
verteilungskämpfe und melden sich
industriebosse zu wort melden sich
ökonomen zu wort die sage das können wir
nicht machen das ist das trifft das herz
des
des wohlstandes in deutschland ja das
trifft den industriellen kern dieses
landes das können wir nicht machen wir
müssen darüber nachdenken ob bestimmte
schlüsselindustrien seit dahin dann im
zweifel energie kriegen gas kriegen und
dann müssen wir mal überlegen wie wir
das in privathaushalten machen also man
kriegt eine idee davon worauf das
hinausläuft
und stell mir das nicht schön vor total
interessante in dem zusammenhang robert
abel hat neulich bei einer rede vor dem
bundesverband der deutschen industrie
hat vor dem pd in den philosophischen
begriff plötzlich ins gespräch gebracht
und davon gesprochen darüber nachgedacht
dass gerade eine art
ungleichzeitigkeit herrscht ja draußen
30 grad und wir müssen uns gedanken
darüber machen dass im winter die böden
kalt bleiben ja das glaube ich auf jeden
fall nur ist es ja ehrlich gesagt noch
nicht einmal abschätzbar wie kalt
also zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt wissen
wir nicht ob tatsächlich das gas
abgestellt wird im winter oder ob es
nicht abgestellt wird naja wenn die
gasspeicher nicht wirklich voll sind
dann wird es irgendwo kalt oder
irgendein prozess in der industrie und
zwar im größeren rahmen findet dann
nicht mehr statt
ja gut und dann kommt das ganz große
thema er wird die wirtschaft schrumpfen
also mal abgesehen von dem einen thema
gesellschaftliche unruhe wechselseitige
missgunst bergrecht gaswerk recht kein
genau ist das zweite dann sinkt das
bruttoinlandsprodukt also da müssen
mehrere firmen können nur noch begrenzt
arbeiten oder manche gar nicht mehr
kapazitäten runterfahren und dann
kommt
quasi über diesen weg etwas von dem
viele leute sagen das muss ja sowieso
kommen na da wir ja keinen zweiten
planeten erde haben und wir unser
extensives wachstum mit dem ökologischen
folgekosten nicht weiter betreiben
können
hätten wir das ja das was wir jetzt
aufgrund des krieges machen dann
irgendwann wald ohnehin aus ökologischen
gründen machen müssen und dann kommen
wir in diese spannende frage geht das
oder geht das nicht ich habe letztens
einen kommentar gelesen in der
frankfurter allgemeinen sonntagszeitung
im wirtschaftsteil da wurde gesagt ja
also die menschen sind nicht bereit zu
verzichten weil das kann man ziemlich
gut da legen anhand der
wirtschaftspsychologie da ist sogar der
satz gesagt worden das hat mit dem
kapitalismus als system nichts zu tun
sondern es hat etwas damit zu tun wie
die menschen so sind
und als beweis wurden dinge angeführt
die tatsächlich in der
wirtschaftspsychologie seit sehr langer
zeit erforscht werden dass die menschen
verlust ja dreimal dramatischer
empfinden einzel gewinnen die haben ja
mal über das spielen geredet wo ich
gesagt hab eigentlich indirekt spielt
man wegen des verlierens weil das das
starke gefühl ist ja und das kennt auch
jeder wenn man seinem kind ein eis
verspricht das cat den wunsch gar nicht
geäußert hat mais haben zu wollen und
sagt ja wenn wir dahin sind an christus
so und dann ist die eisdiele zu ja da
fängt das kind an zu heulen und das
obwohl ist vorher den wunsch nach einem
eis gar nicht gehabt hat das heißt also
diese allein schon der gedanke dass
etwas was man geglaubt hat so haben dass
einem das weggenommen wird macht
menschen schon als kind unglaublich viel
aus
tatsächlich ist das natürlich keine
befriedigende erklärung wir eine richtig
befriedigende erklärung müsste mir
erklären wie kapitalismus egal welcher
spieler hat ja als soziale freie
marktwirtschaft ohne wachstum
funktionieren soll dauerhaft
funktionieren
und ich würde wahnsinnig gerne mal so
dass diese großen ökonomie institute die
wir haben
dew und soweit das institut für
wirtschaftsforschung ifo institut das
die meinen preis ausloben würden so
richtig hoch dotiert für einen ökonomen
der mal ein modell entwirft über ein
kapitalismus der nicht auf wachstum
angewiesen wäre ohne die zustimmung
seiner bürger zu verlieren ich kann mir
da überhaupt nichts darunter vorstellen
ja weil also das ist halt interessant
weil du gerade wirtschaftsinstitute sagt
clemens fuest der ab und zu bei uns in
der sendung ist und den ich sehr schätze
weil nach allem was ich verstehe er ein
sehr sehr guter ökonomisch
der sagt das steht jetzt unser wohlstand
auf dem spiel und weist darauf hin und
das ist ja genau das psychologische
momente um darin seit 1990 hat sich ja
der außenhandel der deutsche
aussenhandel mit waren dienstleistungen
alles was wir so verkaufen und so weiter
fast vervierfacht und das bereinigte pro
kopf einkommen ist um fast 50 prozent
gestiegen
das kann man sagen ja statistik usw
unverhältnismäßigen reich geworden und
andere sind aber auch durchaus amt
geblieben das gibt will ich auch nicht
aber den rufen der kuchen der einbrecher
deutlich größere so genau und wenn jetzt
diese globalisierung
abgewickelt wird und schrumpft dann
führt das natürlich dazu dass
deutschland schrumpft und dann führt das
dazu dass dieser deutsche wohlstand
schrumpft und dann ist sozusagen das
wort verzicht das was den ganz großen
lettern mal plötzlich nach es ist keine
übertreibung zu sagen dann geht alles
kaputt ich möchte überlegen ja jeder
jeder jeder vierte cent der unsere
steuereinnahmen geht in die
bezuschussung der rente was ist denn
wenn die steuereinnahmen dramatisch
sinken
ja wir haben einen wir wollen unter die
besten vier klar kann man was machen man
kann geld finden na das ist das was wir
bei corona gemacht haben viele
milliarden für die bundeswehr werden
auch erfunden werden das ist sozusagen
künstlich neu erzeugt das geld ja und
das heißt wiederum die inflation an und
wenn wir dann eine rezession kriegen
weil wir nicht genug energie haben und
wir bekämpfen das ganze mit dem drucken
von geld also heizen die inflation
anderen erleben wir eine stagnation
das haben wir in der geschichte horne
dass sie da hoffen wir in der geschichte
der bundesrepublik nicht erlebt aber es
gibt ja viele indizien wie ich gerade
sagen die weisen darauf hin dass wir das
bekommen und das ist eine erfahrung die
die heute lebenden generationen also die
über 80-jährigen ausgenommen noch nie
gemacht haben
also wer in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik aufgewachsen ist ja es
gab ein paar kleinen dellen es gab den
anfang der 70er jahre im zusammenhang
mit der ölkrise
es gab ebenfalls letztlich vom öl
ausgelöst der krise ende der 70er anfang
der 80er jahre in fast allen
westeuropäischen denn ein sehr hoher
arbeitslosigkeit und so weiter ja aber
was für mini krise nach verglichen mit
den krisen die man ja beim republik
erlebt hat hyperinflation
arbeitslosigkeit von 6 7 millionen
menschen in deutschland und zog das sind
ja alles dinge die kennen wir gar nicht
und hatten so das gefühl die kommen auch
nie wieder
philosophische interessant ist die frage
man stelle sich mal vor jetzt gebe es
gar keinen knick und es werde unbegrenzt
so weiter gegangen wie vorher das ging
ja auch nicht wegen des
ressourcenverbrauchs also unsere hyper
konsumgesellschaft die kann doch nicht
noch mal der außenhandel sich
vervierfachen in den nächsten 20 25
jahren also wohin sollte das denn auch
führen
und das wird enorm philosophische fragen
auf reden wir auch gleich darüber
richtig wollte nur mal ganz kurz
erklären eine stagnation
das ist so das ist im grunde die die
mutter aller katastrophen wenn du mit
ökonomen sprichst das ist sozusagen die
die fatale kombination aus steigenden
preisen also inflation und dazu
minimales wachstum
es geht sozusagen überhaupt nichts mehr
weiter und das war ja das ding in den
70er jahren da ist das damals im grunde
passiert mit dem öl embargo und diese
stagnation hat damals fast ein jahrzehnt
gedauert ja und und hat uns in
ernsthafte große schwierigkeiten
gebracht aber was man vielleicht mal
erklären muss ist die globalisierung
es wird jetzt häufig so getan als wäre
die globalisierung in gefahr weil putin
diesen krieg angezettelt hat ja das
glaube ich nicht so ist es nicht sondern
die attacken auf die globalisierung gibt
es ja schon seit ein paar jahren wieder
mal an donald trump denkst der den
handelskrieg mit china startet dann
verlässt großbritannien die eu
dann hast du überall plötzlich
populisten die aufkommen von viktor
orban bis personal wo in brasilien usw
die ein und suchen die leute die wir
heute nicht mehr ganz so schlimm finden
bei putin ja noch viel schlimmer ist ja
was machen wir uns über trump über boris
johnson auf das meine ich
jetzt heute wieder also boris johnson
zum beispiel unsere lieben freunde sind
genau das heißt der versuch wirtschaft
zu
rationalisieren das ja das was da
eigentlich stattfindet und das ergebnis
mit das mal angesehen ist total
interessant der welthandel und hatte das
gefühl immer höher weiter schneller und
wie alles jederzeit verfügbar aber wenn
du mal genau hinguckt dann ist der
welthandel in den letzten zehn jahren
schon um fast 5 prozent geschrumpft
und global haben sich investitionen in
den letzten jahren halbiert ja also das
heißt da ist schon etwas im gange
gewesen lange vor diesem krieg und dann
hast du diesen wandel verschiedener
staaten brasilien ist gerade gefallen ja
ich meine person aber das ist ein
rechtsradikaler ich glaube daher nicht
zu nahe will ich das so sage dann reden
wir
über china das ich hin entwickelt zu
einer wirklich harten diktatur auto
garantien und deren übrigens rauchen so
genau aber so ein schwieriger partner
konnte
wo die regierung genau so also ich würde
auch mal sagen diese probleme also wenn
jetzt nicht der russische überfall auf
die ukraine gewesen wären ich meine man
hatte die die amerikaner hatten als
ihren natürlichen feind der gegenwart
und der zukunft immer china im visier
und das ändert sich natürlich auch nicht
durch diesen krieg na also so grausig
das ist was ich da gerade der ukraine
abspielt besteht ja doch die hoffnung
dass das am ende welt historisch nicht
die ganz große zäsur sein wird die zäsur
auf die wir ja auf die wir hier zu
treiben das ist eigentlich eher die
gefahr einer dauerhaften
auseinandersetzungen zwischen den usa
und china auch das war ja eine 100 mal
größere katastrophe noch wäre ja ich
würde gerne nochmal richard das ganze so
zu sagen also die die
die geschichte in einen größeren kontext
stellen dieser tage in interessante zahl
gelesen 60 prozent aller patente
da reden wir jetzt über innovationskraft
über erfindungen werden mittlerweile in
autokratien angemeldet wo wir immer
gesagt haben da können die leute nicht
kreativ sein dass wir einmal so eine
feste regeln uns daher können die
chinesen können nur kopieren ja ja genau
plötzlich 60 prozent aller patente wer
auch immer das berechnet hat aber ich
bin mir sicher dass die zahl stimmt dann
gab es eine zweite sache die ich
interessant fand dieser tage g7 für die
marie zahlen anschaust g7 jetzt in
ellmau ne da treffen sich die anführer
von glaube ungefähr 770 millionen
menschen in china leben so parallel ja
um parallel dazu findet eine
veranstaltung statt der sogenannten bric
staaten brasilien russland indien china
wie sie alle heißen südafrika so die
stehen für über 3 milliarden menschen
und keiner von denen verdammt den
ukraine krieg keiner von denen sagt das
ist ein brutaler angriff skript sondern
wenn überhaupt sind sie maximal dazu
bereit so sagen ja diese bösen bösen
sanktionen aus zum festen ich will sagen
da gibt es einen gigantischen block der
da gerade entsteht ja drei über drei
milliarden versus g 7 770 millionen und
wenn man mal die konsequenzen sich
daraus überlegt was was wird da
passieren und da passieren wird dass wir
nicht mehr wie in der vergangenheit
einfach sagen können okay lass uns im
nach südafrika gehen oder nach china
gehen oder auch nach indien gehen wolle
auch immer einfach dort wo wir maximal
günstig produzieren können sondern
müssen uns jetzt alternativen überlegen
wir werden schauen müssen mit wem können
wir noch handel treiben weil dann vor
dem die noch anderthalb ich verstehe ich
unter dem punkt der am tag und am ende
führt das dazu dass
unser leben insgesamt teurer wird man
könnte auch sagen dass unser wohlstand
schmilzt schrumpft und das bedeutet dass
diese goldenen jahre die wir alle jetzt
so lange jahre speziell in deutschland
genossen haben die sind vorbei
da und das vor dem hintergrund findet
auch diese verzichts debatte statt das
für nicht so interessant gerade also ich
gebe dir sicher in vielem recht aber ich
wage eine andere perspektive ich glaube
berg dass diese phase
in der wir uns in der illusion
einer werte geleiteten aussenpolitik
spiegeln das die nicht von dauer sein
wird also erstens ist es ist ja schon
jetzt eine illusion um meine
lieblingstiere machen saudi arabien
katar hat ja das ist in der beispiel in
das und wichtige handelspartner für
deutschland die auch fest mit der
deutschen industrie verzahnt sind und so
weiter das ginge ja nicht wenn wir
wirklich werte geleitete außenpolitik
ernst meinen und ganz ehrlich glaube ich
dass wir irgendwann wieder an dem punkt
zurückkehren wo wir vor dem
russischen überfall auf die ukraine
standen heißt ich glaube ich glaube dass
ja weiterhin geschäfte mit diktaturen
machen werden ich glaube dass wir uns
glauben aus innenpolitischen gründen
eine werte geleitete außenpolitik nicht
leisten zu können ich glaube dass wir
alle bemühungen machen werden die
riesigen märkte in china die wir haben
und denke an die automobilindustrie und
vieles andere mehr zu halten dass wir
nach wie vor ein interesse daran haben
erstarken der länder in afrika mit
unseren produkten zu versorgen als
exportweltmeister oder vize-weltmeister
der wir sind ich glaube wir werden zu
dem alten zurückkehren kann es kann sein
dass er jetzt ein jahrzehnt erleben wie
das stagnation zu jahrzehnt der 70er
jahre aber ich glaube nicht dass es das
ende der globalisierung ist sondern ich
glaube dass wir irgendwann in die alten
muster zurückkehren werden weil wir
sonst innenpolitisch einen zu
dramatischen preis bezahlen er soll
chrome hat ja gerade einen blauen auge
die präsidentschaft geschafft dabei hat
keine mehrheit mehr hinter sich als
jetzt in der lahme ente und man muss
nicht groß unten um zu sagen dass die
nächste wahl wahrscheinlich dann
tatsächlich von marine le pen gewonnen
wird ja sie haben den dreck sie den
england erlebt schon in relativ
friedlichen umständen verglichen mit den
turbulenzen in denen wir jetzt sind
ich persönlich glaube nicht dass es die
große werte wende geben wird auch nicht
die große regionalisierung ich kann mir
das nicht vorstellen ich schon richard
erwitte wenige dass man was ich mir
wünsche ich schon jetzt davon was ich
für wahrscheinlich an genau und ich also
meine ein gegenargument wäre oder die
frage wäre schlicht und ergreifend was
wenn wir die chance dazu gar nicht mehr
kriegen zurückzukehren zu diesem alten
modell was also soll die anlage nicht
mehr wollen weil ich hier her sind wir
uns nicht mehr was wenn ich meine dass
erklärtes ziel von china dass das china
möglichst autark ist wir haben dieser
tage in der sendung darüber gesprochen
dieses prinzip der zwei kreisläufe das
jahr hoch interessant wenn man sich mal
anschaut wie die chinesische wirtschaft
funktioniert da gibt es sozusagen den
ersten kreislauf in dem nur chinesische
firmen mit chinesischen firmen und
chinesischen kunden ihre geschäfte
machen das betrifft sozusagen wirklich
nur das land und dann gibt es diesen
zweiten kreislauf alles fallen gesteuert
und austariert natürlich von der
kommunistischen partei in dem auch
ausländische unternehmen eine rolle
spielen aber versehen mit dem
unbedingten wunsch möglichst schnellen
unabhängig von denen zu werden arbeitet
autark sein da sagst du noch sehr billig
ja du sagst ja die chinesen jetzt wollen
ist doch genau das hast du vorher für
europa beschrieben hast ja dass wir da
war sie anfangen das zu übernehmen ja
was ich was ich nur sich beschreibt das
nur ich sage nur also wenn du dir die
die kennziffern so anguckt diese
abwicklung der globalisierung
das ist keine gute nachricht und das ist
schon interessant weil wir so viele
jahre haben wir haben wir uns gequält
auch mit dieser globalisierung dann auf
die gefahren dieser globalisierung hin
gewesen und habe nur gesagt was auf das
ist nicht nur gut und verdienen sich ein
paar leute dumm und dämlich und andere
bleiben auf der strecke und vieles an
dieser globalisierungskritik ist ja auch
richtig aber plötzlich merken wir hat
die ein oder andere chlor hühnchen
debatte war vielleicht doch ein bisschen
banane
wir müssen uns jetzt eigentlich mal
überlegen was wir wirklich durch
globalisierung gewonnen haben und sehen
gerade was wir im begriff sind zu
verlieren nämlich echten wohlstand und
da glaube ich
immer klute nochmal zu zitieren ja dass
so die idee die latte macchiato und
hafer mich aber in gesellschaft die die
trifft das richtig aber ist es denn
nicht wirklich so dass die chinesen uns
genauso brauchen wir die also wenn man
im hamburger hafen ist jedes zweite von
diesen riesigen 300 meter langen
container schiffen hoch wie ein hohes
haus ja es kommt aus china
richtig und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass wir in eine welt kommen
wo das wieder zurückgeht ich will mir
nicht vorstellen was im hamburger hafen
los ist und ich will mir gar nicht
vorstellen was überhaupt in diesem land
dann los ist ich glaube die alternative
liegt gar nicht auf dem tisch
natürlich glauben dass richard in die
gruppe von der globalisierung haben ja
haben ja viele profitierten nicht alle
aber sehr sehr viele und wenn man die
rückgängig machen würde würden
unglaublich viele menschen unglaublich
viel verlieren und das würde zu enormen
stabilen zuständen führen das ist ja
genau das problem aber ich sage dir wenn
du dir mal anschaut was da passiert wie
auch die chinesische führung ihre ganz
großen tech firmen wie die die an die
kandare genommen hat jetzt alibaba
tencent und andere die wollten nicht
dass die zu groß werden die wollten
nicht dass der einfluss von denen zu
groß wird wenn du jack ma hörst und
andere den alibaba gründer und so weiter
der dann erst mal monatelang
verschwindet und dann aber nur noch
dinge von sich gibt die sehr im
einvernehmen mit dieser kommunistischen
partei sind dann wird dir klar welcher
machtkampf da hinter den kulissen haben
das was wir uns immer gewünscht haben
dass das in amerika stattfindet und
jemand die gas an die kandare nimmt ja
ja wir machen genau das was hier sich
ganz viele menschen atoll das google
handy
ja das war gedacht deren macht des zu
groß es gibt amerikanische ökonomen die
nicht verdächtig sind ging es zu sein
die gesagt haben diese konzerne müssen
zerschlagen werden ja weil die staaten
im staat werden also die chinesen machen
das und setzen das um wovon auch im
westen viele träumen kann ja kann sein
aber ich schaue jetzt nur an zum
beispiel
russland ist sozusagen für uns jetzt
plötzlich ein land mit dem wir aus guten
gründen nicht mehr großartig handel
treiben wollen nun können führt aber
dazu dass sie sich sofort nach
alternativen umschauen und sich finden
sie auch dass er nicht das ist der
schlechte botschaft oder da haben wir
uns in bordellen hat jetzt genau ich und
dann hab ich auch warum haben wir das
nicht gesehen also warum hat warum war
uns nicht heran so die wahl klar dass
die dass die wirtschaftssanktionen die
wir machen und wir hatten ja so wirklich
auch viele auch viele politiker haben
das ja gesagt wirkt die hoffnung dass
das halt virus nicht lange durch und das
also in dieser welt halt die macht des
westens nicht mehr so groß ist das meine
ich ja also dass er sie sicher vor 30
jahren gewesen
also da hätten wir sicher in einer
situation natur wo die sich nicht ohne
weiteres hätten starke partner oder
riesige absatzmärkte finden genau aber
im grunde genommen kommt das jetzt
sozusagen welthistorischen format
betrachtet das weiß ich zu spät ja das
ist ja das was ich von meinte als ich
diese beiden blöcke beschrieben habe 770
millionen gleich g7 versus über drei
milliarden bric staaten wenn man sich
das mal auf der zunge zergehen lässt
dann versteht man die brauchen uns
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so wie wir
angenommen haben und wenn du hörst wie
putin zum beispiel jetzt laut davon
träumt dass demnächst in russland ganz
viele chinesische autos fahren das dort
chinesische restaurant ketten
auf machen dass dort chinesische
supermarktketten auf machen dass
beispielsweise jetzt schon ein großer
teil weil wir das funktionieren des
zahlungsverkehrs in russland läuft dann
eben nicht mehr über westliche
kreditkarten systeme sondern läuft über
ein chinesisches kreditkarten system
fern sind als dass man die wirtschaft
sagen was morgen gegen die russen ja
entwicklungshilfe auf dem weg chinas zur
größten supermacht und vielleicht ja das
meine ich das sind die unwägbarkeiten
einer gleichwohl hoch globalisierten
welt genau und dazwischen ist dieses
dann doch kleine deutschland dass diese
doppelte abhängigkeit hat ja diese
zweifache abhängigkeit von billigem
russischem gas und das ist gerade
schmerzhaft jetzt sich davon zu lösen
diese diese diese droge sozusagen nicht
mehr zu haben und andererseits extrem
abhängig von den exporten auf diesen
riesenmarkt china ist wir wissen wer da
nicht da nicht das sagen und mein
lieblingswort von helmut schmidt zu
zitieren dass unsere politiker im
hinblick auf den umgang mit der krise
jetzt strategische pygmäen sind das wäre
am ende in dem versuch etwas etwas etwas
moralisch gutes zu tun nur chaos
anrichten
aber sie hat noch mal hatten wir jetzt
mal ernsthaft hatten wir eine wahl
natürlich ist das so aber hatten wir
eine wahrlich frage ernsthaft hatte
irgendjemand in berlin eine wahl welche
wahl hatten die denn wir können doch
nicht ernsthaft sagen gut weil wir nicht
riskieren wollen dass sich die russen
dann den chinesen zu wenden oder indern
oder wem auch immer
lassen wir also würde dann passieren
dinge ja klasse mir das passieren dass
kritisiert ja auch gar nicht ich weiß ja
selber dass ich für die
wirtschaftssanktionen von anfang an
gewesen bin ist auch nichts was ich
kritisiere die frage ist nur dass sie
jetzt weiter weiter und weiter denken
müssen also müssen wir jetzt wirklich
etwas machen was in der politik aus der
mode gekommen ist versuchen möglichst
viele langfristige szenarien
durchzuspielen
also nicht nicht nicht nur reaktiv zu
sein
sondern tatsächlich
langfristiger strategischer
und vielleicht auch weil ich meinen
neuen wegen denken
das ist vielleicht auch eine große
umbruch zeit es ist eine umbruchzeit und
ich noch mal wenn wenn wenn das so
eintritt wie wir es gerade beschreiben
und es gibt ja viele indizien dafür und
hinweise darauf da muss man sagen wird
das definitiv und das sagen die ökonomen
auch es wird dazu führen dass
deutschland wohlstand verliert und und
damit einher geht sozusagen der gedanke
und die idee des des verzichts und ich
wollte ich gerne mal fragen richard
verzichten der in der philosophie epikur
ist so versuchen stichwort dafür ist
muss verzicht etwas schlimmes sein
mäßigung ich meine mäßigung
bandenmäßigen gewinnstrebens wertes
ideal das mag ich natürlich suche einen
griechischen philosophen der nicht ich
werde nicht nach griechenland gesprochen
hat also es gibt welche aber es sind
wirklich wenige alles tippfehler ich
hier nicht davon gesprochen hat aber im
grunde genommen geht je geht die
griechische philosophie immer in die
richtung mit wenig zufrieden sein ja das
ließ sich übrigens leicht sagen und es
gab ja einige philosophen die selber
sehr sehr wohlhabend voran naja durch
die arbeit der der sklaven wer zum
beispiel eine plattform kamen aus einer
der reichsten familien athens platon war
so wohlhabend rs mmc steinreich
wäre heute der sohn von elon musk oder
so wird dazu den 34 reich an den ok ja
aber
der hat ja den grunde genommen
versuchten wirtschaftsmodell zu machen
auch interessant dass die police nicht
wachsen sollte also eher eröffnen die
maßlosigkeit die in kiel die mit dem
materiellen einhergeht und so die ist ja
vor nahezu allen stufen gegeistert
worden genau und das ziel bestand
selbstbeherrschung
gelassenheit ja und den reiz aus wie ich
nicht zu ziehen das ist ja sozusagen der
kern der ip chorischen philosophie das
epikur seinen anhängern gesagt hat ja
ein stück käse ja so richtig bewusst
genossen langsam gegessen lutscht
wahrscheinlich erhalt oder so im
sonnenuntergang
kann ein größerer
genuss sein ja als ein in sich rein
gestopfte mahlzeit als 1000
spektakulären sauerei
dass man also lernen soll den mystischen
funken aus den kleinen dingen zu
schlagen
und das ist ja etwas was viele leute
briefe hat für sich auch akzeptieren
würden ja das vielleicht mal zu machen
oder wie dieser john live einfach mal zu
gehen und zu sagen ich lebe jetzt ein
jahr lang mal so reduziert wie möglich
ein experiment was vielleicht viele
leute bereit werden zu tun manche tun
das ja vielleicht ob manche haben ja
auch wenig ansprüche aber leider lässt
sich diese frage nicht auf der
individual psychologischen ebene
behandeln wir haben keine antwort und
das ist für mich der entscheidende punkt
wie ein wirtschaftssystem funktionieren
kann wenn die menschen auf dem markt
bescheiden werden wir leben ja in einer
bedarfsweckung gesellschaftlich in einer
bedarfsdeckung gesellschaft und wenn es
uns nicht gelingt den den menschen neue
bedürfnisse ein zuflüstern von denen sie
die geahnt haben dass sie sie je gehabt
haben vorher wenn das nicht mehr
funktioniert weil die leute sorgen
brauche ich nicht unbedingt zufrieden
und so weiter mit unsere gesamte
marktwirtschaft nicht mehr funktioniert
also selbst wenn man ist ja nicht so
dass die leute dauerhaft hier gerne
verzichten wollen aber selbst wenn es so
wäre es wäre das schlimmste was unseren
system überhaupt passieren kann im
wirtschaftssystem ist der bescheidene
konsumenten zufriedenheit zufriedenheit
darf es aus ökonomischen gründen niemals
geben wenn alle leute zufrieden sind ist
eine katastrophe in wirtschaftliches
wissen was für ein gruseliges weltbild
dass du da gerade mal ist das ist ja
fürchterlich oder da ja eigentlich dass
das wäre das unser ganzes system darauf
aufgebaut ist menschen chronisch
unzufrieden zu halten das ist
tatsächlich der fall das ist der sinn
von werbung
menschen chronisch unzufrieden zu halten
wie du das schön ausgedrückt hast
krass ich habe in der vorbereitung ikone
es gibt kennst du christoph rabe
eigentlich von der von der lmu in
münchen ist ein philosoph ja der etwas
total interessantes gesagt hat der sagt
was auf ich zum thema es ist total
interessant wie wir hören oft von leuten
die sagen ja ich bin hedonist und dazu
stehe ich auch ja ist das leben lustvoll
genießen und möchte möchte alles was
geht und und am besten 24 stunden lang
der christoph rath verweist auf etwas
sehr interessant ist da sagt bei epikur
ist das besondere am hedonismus dass er
im grunde nur zwei zustände zu lässt
nämlich lust und das gegenteil davon
unlust und das hat sagt er und das fand
ich so spannend eine wichtige konsequenz
denn wenn die abwesenheit von unlust
schon lust ist dann ist es relativ
einfach lust zu erreichen das heißt lust
bedeutet in dem fall nicht maximal
konsumieren machen mal haben wollen
glaubt sondern sich eigentlich freuen
dass man gerade nicht leidet dass ihm
ein ko es geht ja noch der pico war
selber sehr krank ja und dann schwer
gelitten ja woran und er versucht
sozusagen auch noch seinen seinen
jüngern war ja so eine art guru zu
predigen ja dass man sich erstens wenn
man schmerzen hat sich vorstellen könnte
man hätte noch größere schmerzen
genommen ja und dass man dann sagt kann
der herr so schlimm ist das alles nicht
oder sich im zweifelsfall sagt man
sollte sich vielleicht nicht so wichtig
nehmen
oder dass man auch sagt man kann sich
sogar in die lage versetzen seine
schmerzen zu genießen ja wenn ich nicht
zu extremen sind weil man auf diese art
und weise seinen körper und seine
körperlichen gespürt also die freiheit
von schmerz ist sozusagen schon lust
riecht und wenn wir feststellen dass ein
gut
dass wir begehren bis auf total auch
zweiter total guter gedanke zum thema
werbung ja wenn wir merken dass ein gut
das wir begehren nur sehr schwer
verfügbar ist dann kann das pico zufolge
schon ein zeichen dafür sein dass wir es
eigentlich gar nicht brauchen
das ist auch ein sehr guter gedanke
finde ich ja kommen wir natürlich ist
eine absolut guter gedanke kommen wir
natürlich wieder auf die ebene wenn wir
alle in korea wären ja dann wird der
kapitalismus nicht mehr funktionieren
und es ist auch interessant die peak uhr
war in der sowohl zu lebzeiten aber erst
recht später der meistgehasste
griechische philosoph vielleicht die
christen haben die schriften ep kurs
sämtlich verbrannt und zwar so sämtlich
das kaum noch was von ihnen erhalten ist
ein wirklicher ja aber wer sieht wie
korea waren sozusagen also die großen
schweine figur hatte den beinamen das
große schwein ich weiß ja dass man hat
ihn also verdammt und man hat ihm
angedichtet etwas was da alles für üble
sachen ein seiner kommune sich da
abgespielt haben und so weiter weil
diese haltung also mit den kleinen
dingen zufrieden zu sein etwas ist was
überhaupt wieder zu einer starts noch zu
einer wirtschafts idee passt für die
christen war es ja wahnsinnig wichtig
nur über arbeit wir haben darüber
gesprochen dass man sich über arbeit
quasi für sie bereich qualifiziert diese
haltung von epikur die ganze er die
ganze zeit darum zu liegen ja und seine
these zu lutschen etwas übertrieben
ausgedrückt ist genau das gegenteil der
fall aber richard was heißt das denn
jetzt also verzichten was werden wir den
highlights in den nächsten wochen und
monaten leben glaubst du dass dann die
die zuständig dafür sind jemand ist ja
schon bemerkenswert wenn ein fdp
finanzminister sagt mangel das ist ja
richtig dass er harte rhetorik ab drei
vier fünf jahren so genau konnte das
nicht sagen christian lindner oder wenn
robert habeck sagt das wird schlimmer
als bei corona ich meine das ist ja so
eine rhetorik das ist käme ja gar nicht
mehr
ja und was außer dem moment als sie in
die regierung kam haben sie sich das
alles so nicht vorgestellt
das kann man auf jeden fall sein also
ich glaube nicht dass christian nimmt
noch vor hatte als finanzminister des
mangels in die geschichte einzugehen ja
so etwas interessanter ist eben ich
hatte das ja am eingang gesagt
für die grünen wäre verzichte eigentlich
ein wichtiger begriff weil in ihren
ursprüngen spielte der herde große rolle
genau anfang der 80er jahre haben die
grünen gesagt wir können nicht so
weiterleben wie bisher
unser wir können keine autobahnen mehr
bauen wir müssen den innerdeutschen
luftverkehr abschaffen ja wir können uns
unser leben nicht mehr leisten weil der
ökologische tribut zu hoch ist und weil
wir auf die art und weise im planeten
kaputt machen und das ist wirklich ein
treppenwitz meine 40 jahre später 42
jahre später sind sie in eine regierung
ja und aus einem völlig anderen motive
aus müssen sie jetzt verzicht zur
politischen kategorie machen
das ist ehrlich gesagt verrückt naja
aber trotzdem ist es realistisch also
die ja du hast recht also wenn du
überlegst auch wohl wozu wir jetzt alles
bereit sind und auch bereit sein müssen
weil wir jetzt im winter nicht frieren
wollen und dann die große angst
sozusagen vor sozialen unruhen vor
sozialen verwerfungen die dann dazu
führt dass dass die politik jetzt
wirklich reagiert dass man dinge tut die
man längst für
erledigt zu
[Musik]
erledigen wir erledigt zu haben glaubte
so genau
und jetzt musst du plötzlich wieder
kohlekraftwerke anwirft und muss
plötzlich wie der braunkohle kraftwerke
an werfen die die ganzen sachen musst
über
religiöses tracking gas nachdenkt so
weiter alles dauert so hat sich robert
habeck seinen job nicht vorgestellt so
und das sind wir alles jetzt bereit im
angesicht dieser krise zu tun und ich
frage mich manchmal
warum schaffen wir es an dem punkt die
pobacken zusammenkneifen und warum an
anderer stelle nicht kriegt natürlich
auch das ist die zentrale frage oder
sind die zentrale frage genau genau also
warum kann der der der ukraine krieg das
auslösen was wir aus ökologischen
gründen längst hätte machen müssen
natürlich nicht kohle kraftwerke weiter
laufen lassen das natürlich nicht aber
zu sagen noch pragmatisch zu zu sagen im
prinzip ist genug da jetzt ist es eine
frage wie wir das an dem essen verteilen
und es muss nicht um jeden preis mehr
werden weil das ist ja quasi das
philosophische sich im hintergrund
abspielt und das ist ja etwas was ich
vorhin sagte das ist eigentlich die dna
der grünen gewesen bis vor 20 jahren ja
aber die ersten 20 jahre ihres bestehens
war dass ihre dna und jetzt werden sie
aus einem ganz ganz anderen motiv kommen
sie daraufhin zurück und jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt ob sie dann sei es aus
diesem motiv es schaffen den deutschen
ein bisschen verzicht beizubringen ich
bin hoch gespannt ja aber ich gucke das
als mir an als aus das beunruhigte
zuschauer ich sehe das auch als eine
sehr sehr gefährliche situation in der
wir uns befinden
man kann immer noch sagen deutschland
ist natürlich stabiler als etwa
frankreich
also ich denke in frankreich ist die
situation wesentlich gefährlicher als
die in deutschland ist aber man sollte
das auch bei uns nicht unterschätzen und
den usa ist sie ebenfalls gefährlich
dass seitens beiden regierungsantritt
hat sich der benzinpreis verdoppelt in
den usa
und die inflation ist da ja auch
zwischenzeitlich bis auf 10 prozent
hochgeschnellt also das könnte ein
überragender sieg für donald trump bei
der nächsten wahl werden das ist wahr
diesmal zum schluss noch mal gefragt
richard ganz persönlich nur weil man
denkt darüber nach für dich jetzt auch
verzicht worauf können zu verzichten was
was wird die schwer fallen was wärst du
bereit zu tun ist eine frage die wir
jetzt uns alle stellen müssen es geht
jetzt nicht um die frage ob man morgens
drei minuten länger du stocker nicht nur
so einfach ist ja also tatsächlich
tatsächlich friere ich nicht leicht und
das liegt daran ich bin in einem zimmer
ohne heizung groß geworden das heißt es
gab eine heizung aber es gab keinen
thermostat an der heizung also dieses
kleine zimmer sechs quadratmeter wurde
entweder unglaublich heiß oder kalt
und daraufhin beschlossen meine eltern
die heizung wird nicht angemacht und ich
kann mich als kind erinnern die die
bettdecke immer warm gestrampelt zu
haben wir können also das ganz ganz ganz
wild darunter bewegt um über die körper
hitze genug wärme zu erzeugen was
übrigens gut funktioniert und wir sind
auch im winter häufig dann den dicken
pullis zuhause rumgelaufen und wurde
sehr sehr wenig geheizt das hat dann zur
folge dass ich tatsächlich wenig frieren
und ich könnte mir vorstellen ich habe
auch kein problem kalt zu duschen oder
also diese diese dass das weniger wird
heizkosten das waren weniger heitz so
das könnte ich mir vorstellen und weiß
ein auto fahre ich sowieso nicht und
dann muss ich nicht groß drauf
verzichten das tue ich ohnehin
aber worauf würde man verzichten selten
ein urlaub fliegen würde man sicher auch
könnte ich auch drauf verzichten dazu
müsste ich weiter nachdenken worauf
kommt man alles verzichtet einmal
richtig ernsthaft darüber nachdenkt wenn
man weiß man muss dann kann man
wahrscheinlich auf vieles verzichten ich
glaube dass das geht die frage ist doch
immer nur wie lange
eine 102 winter oder für nun an mein
leben lang dann war es doch sehr großen
unterschied aus aber dass die menschen
sich daran gewöhnen sich auf einer
wohnung im winter police anzuziehen da
sehe ich nicht den untergang des
abendlandes drin
das glauben ja auch ich fürchte nur
damit könnte es möglicherweise nicht
getan sein jetzt komme ich aber jetzt
auch mal mit was vor recht schlecht wäre
beim verzichten
grillen ich grille gegen ganze noch mal
durch quatsch wirklich bin gehören sie
diese villa zu diesem grillmeister naja
eigentlich dein herz doch ich bin ein
griller und und und das ist eben so die
sache also das ist auch ein gasgrill und
ich jetzt wüsste ich müsste ich müsste
darauf verzichten würde man sich
vielleicht in anderen grill anschaffen
aber dann würde man die ganze
nachbarschaft fertig machen mit dem er
auch davon dass christa diesbezüglich
sozusagen am schonendsten
nein aber das würde mir etwas ausmachen
ich würde es natürlich tun klar wenn man
muss kann man auf alles mögliche von
sich ein klares subjektiv würde würde
mir das nicht leicht fallen diese
gemütlichkeit auf der terrasse zu sitzen
und zubehör esse sowas du warst in der
weltgeschichte unterwegs du kommst nach
hause ja das würde mir schwer fallen
aber machbar also bei mir zum beispiel
ich ich war relativ wenig auto fahre
viel fahrrad weil ich das privileg ab in
der stadt zu leben ja braucht man
eigentlich gar kein auto ab und zu mal
brauche ich das aber es sagt dir ganz
offen oder niemand kommen würde würde
sagen jetzt gibst du dein auto ab oder
jetzt fährst du gar kein auto mehr zum
beispiel am sonntag und am samstag oder
was auch immer das wird mir schwerfallen
zwar nie gegen den automatischen
sonnentag den dom mit dem du da
lambsdorff konfrontiert hast genau
würdest du sagen das ist nicht zumutbar
nein das habe ich nicht gesagt natürlich
ist das zumutbar ist eine frage wie
lange geht das dann so bei mir ist das
was anderes und deswegen ist so
interessant bei dir es ist das grillen
hätte ich jetzt nie vermutet ja aber
jeder hat einen anderen träger punkt du
musst dir vorstellen die welt aus der
ich komme ja irgendwo dabei heidi und
peter auf der alm er den dolomiten
wunderschön aber
zentral ja wenn man dort aufwächst das
wichtigste überhaupt ist irgendwann
einen fahrbaren untersatz zu haben und
idealerweise dann irgendwann ein auto zu
haben bei dem winter ist wird es dort
sehr sehr kalt das auto ist für mich
verbunden mit freiheit das ist für mich
ein absolutes synonym für freiheit auto
ist für mich so sagen die flucht ja raus
aus etwas das ich vielleicht dann
irgendwann auch nicht mehr wollte und
deswegen hat es als auto für mich von
ganz ganz hoher symbolik auch wenn ich
es relativ wenig nutzer aber einfach zu
wissen dass sie es könnte wenn nach der
ferne ist mit einer generation stirbt
diese symbolik aus also dass das ach ja
dass das also das auto als inbegriff der
freiheit das kann nur erlebt haben wer
vor 1980 geworden also darüber hinaus
ist das alltagsrassismus was hier wieder
läuft ja aber das ist ein spaten segment
für für heute
halten sich mit nein das spart so ab
dass das auto ist für die junge
generation hat das nicht bei entfernt
diese bedeutung ist verschieden und
zweitens am anfang gesagt die menschen
sind wesentlich anpassungsfähiger als
sie selber glaubt du auch also wir
werden vielleicht in die situation
kommen im nächsten jahr na du fährst
kein auto mehr und ich grädel nicht mehr
und dann treffen wir uns ein jahr später
wieder und gucken ob wir unglücklicher
geworden sind ist nicht dein ernst und
dann trinken wir kaffee milch cappuccino
oder was ich habe noch nie in meinem
leben milch getrunken
wirklich nicht ich weiß nicht wie das
schmeckt
anders ja aber ist okay man gewöhnt sich
daran sagt es ganz gut
richard das war
vielleicht ein bisschen beunruhigend
aber epikur dass das ist jetzt das woran
ich mich für den rest der woche
festhalte ja die erbe wesenheit von
schmerz ist auch schön schön ist wenn
der schmerz nachlässt was ist man so
sagen ja der schmerz über das nicht mehr
grillen können nicht mehr auto fahren
können und so weit auch der welt schmerz
über die umgehende weltgeschichte so
genau und weißt du was ironisch ist ich
verrate dass jetzt ausnahmsweise ich
muss jetzt gleich in die aufzeichnung
und krieg gerade eine sms passt wirklich
schon fast
dass sie sich verspätet und die junge
frau die das schreibt heißt blueser
neubauer und du willst seiten bei der
flug nein nein nein nein nein nein sie
schreibt der zug und ich schleppen und
sie hier durch den niedersächsische
prärie in der hoffnung irgendwann an zu
kommen in diesem sinne wird vielen dank
[Musik]
eine produktion von m 52 und popstars
bei ohren er im auftrag des zdf